we begin with breaking news here at six
o'clock police report an armed robbery
turned into a Chase that's causing some
long delays on the I-15 this is a live
look right now a few just a few
Northbound Lanes between Spring Mountain
and Sahara are shut down as you can see
slowly we're seeing a little bit of
traffic now finally moving thank you for
joining us here at six o'clock I'm
Denise Valdez and I'm Brian Loftis Metro
reports it ended right near the Sahara
exit police say the suspect shot himself
before police officers could take him
into custody a news now investigator
Vanessa Murphy live now with more
details
interstate 18 Northbound right near the
Las Vegas Strip still shut down during
rush hour I'll step out of the way so
you can see this scene this major
investigation on the interstate you can
see that black SUV we're not going to
zoom in too close because it appears
there is still a body inside police say
this all started with a carjacking near
Buffalo and blue diamond around 12 this
afternoon police say they believe they
spotted the suspect's vehicle a car
chase took place and it ended right here
police say the suspect shooting himself
before they could get to him again this
is a major investigation a huge police
presence here on Interstate 15 you have
a mobile command center again that's
where those larger scale investigations
you have the police Union's bus here
talking with officers as they represent
officers who were involved here again
Interstate 15 Northbound shut down down
between Spring Mountain and Sahara it
appears this will not be open for some
time reporting live Vanessa Murphy 8
News Now